bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france la réunion de la cedeao
concernant la crise mayenne prévue pour
demain finalement reporté ce que vous
avez des informations sur cette décision
et qu'est ce que ça peut changer surtout
qu'est ce que ça signifie
sur le déroulé des négociations je crois
que les dirigeants de la cedeao évolué
marche sur des oeufs par rapport à la
situation au mali qui n'ont pas il
n'était pas particulièrement bien vu
bien perçue par la population qui a
estimé qu'elle avait été lâché par les
dirigeants de la cedeao qui est
considéré par les populations comme un
club de chefs d'état qui se soutiennent
quoi qu'il arrive au détriment de leur
population cependant il est quand même
plus cette inflexion dans la position à
la fois de la population du m51 rfp
ainsi que de la junte militaire qui a
permis que des négociations s'ouvrent et
que aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est de savoir si déjà au niveau
de l'embargo qui a été relativement
allégée puisque les banques peuvent à
nouveau fonctionner cet embargo a été
allégé mais l'idée c'est de trouver une
solution pour la suite avec une
transition qui sera conduite soit par
des militaires soit par des civils et
donc vu que tous les mouvements n'ont
pas encore pu trouver un nom sur lequel
ils s'entendraient pour faire une
proposition
je pense que c'est à ce niveau là que la
cedeao vous a voulu laisser du temps aux
différents acteurs sur le terrain pour
arriver avec des solutions et non pas
faire un choix dans la précipitation
malgré ces trois jours de négociations
on est face à une véritable impasse pour
le mali qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de
ces négociations entre la cedeao et et
la junte
la première chose que je retiens c'est
que le président de la république a
demandé qu'il n'y ait pas d'embargo sur
son pays et que la dimension humanitaire
soient prises en compte pour ne pas
aggraver la situation des maliens qui
souffre déjà de plusieurs crises à la
fois la crise sécuritaire la crise
économique la crise sanitaire à laquelle
vient s'ajouter cette crise politique
dont il a préféré s'effacer et donc
laisser une chance au dialogue pour les
maliens afin que son pays ne soit pas
plus à terre qu'il ne l'est déjà par la
crise multiforme qui le traverse et donc
à présent il est question de savoir si
tous les acteurs arriveront malgré le
fait que le m5 rfp et été dépassé par
les militaires qui ont réussi ce qu'il
essaie d'obtenir depuis le mois de juin
qu'il ait pu obtenir la démission du
président de la république
maintenant la balle est dans le camp des
acteurs politiques de la société civile
et de tous les acteurs qui pourront
concourir à cette transition au côté des
militaires alors cette transition
militaire pourrait être impliqué trois
ans de pouvoir militaire est ce que
c'est vraiment envisageable
et qu'est ce que ça a pourrait impliquer
pour le pays
[Musique]
pour l'instant il est difficile de se
remettre et concrètement comment les
choses vont se passer les militaires on
tique qu'il ne voulait pas être les
seuls acteurs d'abord ils ont dit qu'ils
ne s'agissait pas d'un coup d'état
militaire
ce qui fait que les sanctions de la
cedeao qui sont appliquées
automatiquement en coup d'état n'ont pas
pu être activée maintenant qu'ils ont
choisi la voie du respect du cadre
constitutionnel du pays
on peut demander le retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel mais c'est
inconstitutionnel n'a pas été rompu le
président à démissionner il a confirmé
sa volonté de démissionner les
militaires veulent travailler de façon
consensuelle avec tous les acteurs de la
vie politique et de la vie associative
est donc aujourd'hui il faut que les
négociations à la fois entre les maliens
mais aussi et surtout entre les maliens
et la communauté internationale c'est à
dire les partenaires du mali bilatéraux
les partenaires multilatéraux au sein du
g5 celle au sein de la minus ma au sein
de la cedeao que tous ses partenaires là
arrivent à trouver des interlocuteurs et
qu'avec ses interlocuteurs ils trouvent
un terrain d'entente pour la poursuite
de la de la vue de la de la coopération
qui avaient été engagées entre le mali
et ses partenaires là par le
gouvernement précédent vient de leurs
questions rapidement on l'a évoqué
braille boubacar keïta renonce à diriger
son pays c'est ce qu'il a déclaré à la
cedeao un aveu qui va forcément
conforter les pouvoirs militaires dans
leurs opérations
elle avait aussi qui conforte la
population puisqu'il souhaitait la
démission de leur président mais ce
qu'il y à tout même à des craintes à
avoir pour la population malienne durant
cette période de transition des craintes
de chaos complètement dans le pays
la situation semble maîtrisée sur le
plan politique au niveau de bamako est
d'aider la partie sud du pays
je veux dire comparativement au grand
nord qui est encore sous la coupe des
mouvements jihadistes dans le sud
l'impression générale c'est qu'il n'y a
pas eu de débordement
il ya eu quelques scènes de pillage dans
les premières heures du coup d'état
mais tout cela était très vite contrôler
et cela donne l'impression d'une
certaine maîtrise de la part des
putschistes est ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui éviter c'est que les
sanctions et l'embargo qui pourraient
être prononcés contre le mali viennent
aggraver une situation qui est déjà
compliquée n'oublions pas que le pays
est quand même dans une grande crise
économique dans une crise politique
également et que si l'on venait à grave
et cela avec un embargo la fermeture des
frontières et le non approvisionnement
du mali qui est un pays de l'hinterland
il n'a pas de corte il n'a pas
d'ouverture sur la mer cela serait
vraiment un désastre pour les
populations
merci beaucoup lui et que nous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président du club de
l'information africaine